hey i'm nancy miller from wired magazine
this is wired play
where each week we look through pop
culture the wired lens
i'm here with rob capps a fellow senior
editor hi single ladies
and adam rogers fellow senior editor at
wired magazine
hi rob single ladies
so this is beyonce's single ladies put a
ring on it
and what we've noticed while watching
this video of course we're always in the
office watching beyonce videos
is that there's actually there's
actually no ring on beyonce's hand in
this video
it's a robot she says
the robot hand as we all know is the
first sign that you're heading to the
dark side
i guess that makes jay-z the emperor
there can be only one
are always two there are there can be
only one highlander you fool
always two there are right there can be
only two that's why he killed rihanna no
there could be
more empire more problems beyonce said
they could rule the gala galaxy together
but then
jay-z's like no that's not anything all
right so refresh my memory
what's the symbolism of the losing of
the hand
well i'm sorry before you get to the
loop thing
how do they the one in the middle is
beyonce right are they clones on the
outside
so there's like a c-3po beyonce on the
left yeah i thought there could be only
two
one of them has to die this is clearly
the clone army
but you're right about this those hip
joints though those are that's
that's robotics right i'm sorry i
interrupted you explain to explain the
significance of the robot
well no you know you know anakin loses
his hand and he becomes darth vader
becomes more machine than man luke loses
his hand way to spoil those movies dude
he has a choice to make about whether to
join the dark side luke
you know beyonce loses her hand because
she's married you know
or so or is this just is the rest of her
robot and they just
forgot to put makeup on that part it's
like in the pilot of fringe when that
woman peels off that whole uh
peels off her hand and she uh robot hand
trend alert
i'm saying they're they're everywhere so
how much does one of these robot hands
cost rob you know a lot about robotics
beyonce she's pretty expensive
she's got a taste but no no not beyonce
now now without a three pack
so if you're thinking someone who's
loved don't cost a thing you're thinking
of jlo not beyonce
okay let's just put it that way you know
we shouldn't we should note that this
isn't actually beyonce this is beyonce's
alter ego sasha
fierce so sasha fierce now fierce is
is a thing
i just love the image of like that first
time you see darth vader and star wars
when he comes on to the rebel arcade
runner with all the smoke and slaps his
ass a little bit
i i think that the idea of if that was
actually sasha fierce instead of darth
vader i think that would have been
yeah you pick star wars we'll watch
wow